me and the boy wear the same shoe size
he wants a pair of Air Jordan fours for
Christmas i buy them and then i steal
him from his closet like a twisted
Grinch themed episode of blackish the
kicks are totems to my youth I wear them
like mercury on my black man's feet I
can't get those young freedom days back
fast enough
last time I was really fast I was 16
outrunning a doorman on the Upper East
Side
he caught me vandalizing his building
not even on some artsy stuff just stupid
of all the genders boys are the
stupidest 16 was a series of barely
getting away and never telling my
parents I assume that my son is
stewarding this tradition well 16 was
the low end theory and Marvin Gaye on
repeat 16 is younger than Trayvon and
older than Emmett Till at the DMV my
boys in line to officially enter his
prime suspect years young Brown and
behind the wheel of moving semaphore
signaling the threat of communities from
below on top of the food chain humans
have no natural predator but America
plays out something genetically embedded
and instinctual in its appetite for the
black body America guns down black
bodies and then walks around them board
like laconic lions next to half-eaten
gazelles bloody lips America and the
black body on some Nat Geo
well he passes his road test at the DMV
he does the strut c-walk broken
fortnight thing on the way in to finish
his paperwork true joy and calibrated
cool on the eye of my filming iPhone the
victory dance of someone who's just
salvaged a draw he's earned this win but
he's so 16 he can't quite let his body
be fully free when he's three I'm in
handcuffs in downtown Oakland five
minutes ago I was illegally parked now
I'm in the back of a squad car
considering the odds that I'm going to
die here 15 minutes away from my son who
expects that in 18 minutes daddy's gonna
pick him up from preschool there are no
pocket-sized cameras to capture this
moment so I learned a lot of big words
when I was 16 getting ready for the SAT
but none of them come to me now in the
police car the only thing that really
speaks is my skin I know this I was
parked on a bus zone on 12th and
Broadway running to the ATM on the
corner I pulled the cash out just as the
police car pulls up behind me
give him the aw shucks my bad that
Ernest black man face he waits til I'm
back in the police car and then hits the
siren takes my license with his hand on
the gun comes back two minutes later gun
drawn another patrol car now four cops
now my face on the curb hands behind my
back shackled I'm angry and humiliated
only until I'm scared and then sad I
smell like the last gasp before my own
death I think how long the boy will wait
before he realizes that daddy is not on
his way I think his last barely formed
memory of me will be the story of how I
never came for him I try to
telepathically say goodbye the silence
brings me no peace the quiet makes it
hard to rest in the void there is anger
mushrooming in the moss at the base of
my thoughts a fungus growing on the
spine of my freedom attempts I'm free
from all except contempt the spirit of
an unarmed civilian in a time of civil
unrest no peace just Marvin Gaye
falsettos arching like a broken wing
Sparrow competing against the empty
sirens singing the police
apparently some cat from Richmond had a
warrant out on him and when the cop says
my name to dispatch Jude doesn't hear
mark Joseph he hears Mike Johnson I
count seven cars and 18 cops on the
corner now a pride around a pound of
flesh by the grace of God I'm not fed to
the Beast
today magnanimously the first cop makes
sure to give me a ticket for parking in
a bus zone before he sets me free the
boy is 16 here's a license to drive in
the hollow city enough body to fill my
shoes I have gray in my beard
and it tells the truth he can navigate
traffic in the age of autonomous
vehicles you know people say the talk
like the thing happens just once like my
memory has been erased and my internet
is broken like I can't read today's
martyred named like today's the day that
I don't love my son enough to tell him
bro I really don't care about your
rights yo your mission is to get home to
me live to tell me the story boy get
home to me today's talk is mostly
happening in my head as he pulls onto
the freeway and Marvin Gaye comes on the
radio I'm wearing the boys shoes and the
tune in my head is the good vibe that I
almost never said a good vibe the length
of a requiem a kiss a whiff of his neck
the length of a revelation and a request
flying high in the friendly sky without
ever leaving the ground my pain is a
walking bass line a refrain placated
stress against a fading baseline listen
this is not to be romantic but to assert
a plausible scenario for the existential
moment driving while black is its own
genre of experience ask Marvin it may
not be the reason why you sing like an
angel but it surely has something to do
with why heaven bends to your voice the
boy driving the cop in the rearview
mirror is a ticket to ride or die when
you give a black boy the talk you pray
he is of the faction of the fraction
that survives you pitch him the
frequency of your telepathic goodbye
channel the love sustained in Marvin's
upper register under his skullcap
black music at its best is an exploded
black hole responding to the call of
America at its worst strike us down the
music lives dark like tar or tobacco or
cotton in muddy water gets home to me
son like a Love Supreme
a God as love a love over rules feathers
for the angelic lifts of the Restless
dead like a theme for trouble man or
sixteen year old boy free to make
mistakes and live through them grow from
them holy holy
Mercy Mercy Me Mercy Mercy
[Music]
[Applause]